[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce nouveau numéro du sky
échos le magazine qui vous parle de la
vie économique de saint quentin en
yvelines au programme de cette édition
nous parlerons de l'événement paris
saclay spring et de l'univers des
startups à saint quentin en yvelines
avec notre invité qui sera avec nous
dans toutes les missions and five
aujourd hui nicolas directrice du
développement économique saint quentin
en yvelines et donc voici le sommaire de
ce 38e numéro du skype
c'est la convention d'affaires des
acteurs de l'innovation de paris saclay
la quatrième édition de spring
rassemblera notamment des start-up
saint-quentinoise elle participe à
l'expansion de la santé numérique
michael développe des solutions pour
faciliter le suivi thérapeutique des
cancers enfin la star tabac flayac en
soi une application pour permettre la
réutilisation de matériaux lors de la
destruction d'un bâtiment pour cela elle
collabore avec site ey alors anne failli
on va parler des start-up comment il se
porte sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines nos startups père se porte
bien nous avons la chance d'avoir des
entrepreneurs qui ont eu de nombreux
succès en cours d eau qu des derniers
mois avec des levées de fonds de
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
l'arrivée de grands comptes aussi dans
l'eure dans leur capital et et on le
voit dans tous les secteurs dans le
secteur du e-commerce c'est évidemment
là à le succès de hauteur x c'est aussi
celui de s es accessoires qui donc tous
les deux s'imposent comme des leaders
dans leur secteur dans le domaine du
e-commerce c'est la levée de fonds de
prophétie dans le domaine de la de la
cybersécurité c'est l'arrivée de
michelin au capital de leurs captifs ces
derniers mois on était vraiment porteur
de très très bonnes nouvelles pour ce
tissu d'autres preneurs extrêmement
proactif des secteurs à forte
technologie et cela malgré la crise
sanitaire et cela malgré la crise
sanitaire certains d'ailleurs si on
pense au domaine de la cybersécurité en
plus tôt vu leur business se développer
à l'aune du développement évidemment du
numérique et du digital et donc le tissu
économique de saint quentin en yvelines
dans les pme qui ont été très proactifs
dans les plans de relance comme dans les
startups montre non seulement sa
résilience mais sa capacité de gagner
encore des parts de marché alors
e-commerce vous avez parlé de la
cybersécurité il ya deux domaines aussi
peut-être qu'ils s'inscrivent dans la
tendance actuelle notamment la green
tech peut-être ou ou la santé aussi
alors dans le domaine de la green tech à
saint quentin en yvelines est une
berceau dans le secteur de la
construction et c'est évidemment des
éléments que que l'on va voir au travers
des différentes start-up que vous avez
interrogé donc de nombreux sujets de
développement d'innovation dans lesquels
nos entreprises sont leaders dans le
domaine de la santé également
de nombreuses startups en lien avec
notre ufr de santé je pense à sky
therapeutics qui est né au coeur de
l'ufr en 1900 en 2015 pardon et qui
aujourd'hui salon de nouveaux locaux
relocalise une partie de la production
jusqu'à maintenant développer en
allemagne dont sur l'ensemble de ses
secteurs les entreprises montrent leur
capacité d'innovation et puis
d'attraction de talent je suivais voilà
vous parler de la santé on va regarder
notamment ce reportage sur michael
michael c'est quoi c'est une start up
spécialisée dans la e-santé et qui est
basée à montigny le bretonneux elle
développe plusieurs solutions numériques
pour faciliter le suivi thérapeutique
contre le cancer regardez c'est la
séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
je suis christophe vergne le fondateur
et président de michael
liles coop notre activité et dans la
e-santé ce qu'on appelle la santé
numérique
[Musique]
nous travaillons sur une aide aux
professionnels de santé en oncologie
notamment dans leur prise de décision
il faut savoir que les professionnels
ont aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
donner d'informations à gérer et donc le
métier rendu plus difficile à la fois
dans pour une meilleure prise en charge
des patients mais également pour la
recherche clinique ou encore des
développements une intelligence
artificielle
nous avons développé à ce jour trois
outils le premier est un outil développé
par maicon est un tableau de bord pour
les rcp et ce tableau de bord permet de
visualiser les informations toutes les
informations critiques pertinentes
sur un patient donné qui va être
discutée dans le cadre de ces de ces
réunions un deuxième qui consiste qui
est une interface patients qui consiste
à capter les symptômes du patient qui
est en traitement et un troisième en
fait qui est une interface pour
l'infirmière de pratiques avancées
qu'elle a on va dire une sorte de
monitoring d'outils de monitoring du
patient avec à la fois le plan
thérapeutique qui a été choisi et la
remontée des symptômes de ces patients
le premier outil est validée et
commercialiser
les deux autres sont surtout aujourd'hui
dans le cadre d'une dévaluation
académique que je citais
les structures hospitalières en europe
la structuration des données et la
validation clinique des données que nous
que nous opérons au travers de la
solution my people permet d'aller sur
d'autres marchés qui peuvent en être
plus sur la recherche clinique où le
développement de nouvelles solutions en
numérique et là en fait qui ouvre le
champ des possibles nous avons quelques
quelques discussions en cours de ce
point de vue là on vient de découvrir my
people va participer à paris saclay et
spring qui se tiendra le 12 et 13 mai
prochains à l'école polytechnique situé
à palaiseau c'est une convention
d'affaires en présence des acteurs de
l'innovation est d'ailleurs qu'à une
cinquantaine de start up présenté qui
dont certaines qui viennent de saint
quentin en yvelines sur six villages
thématiques ça représente quoi paris
saclay ce prime pour 50 ans du bim c'est
un événement qui s'est imposé depuis
2010 9 comme étant l'événement en
matière d'innovation en ile de france
c'est un événement joue collectif
l'ensemble des territoires
l'agglomération de paris saclay
versailles grand parc saint quentin en
yvelines notre ambition c'est de
valoriser bien sûr nos startups nos
grands comptes et puis l'ensemble de
notre écosystème en matière
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
c'est le moment et pour les
investisseurs français et internationaux
de découvrir ce formidable écosystème
qui est celui de paris saclay avec
l'ensemble de ces composantes
territoriales qui sont extrêmement
complémentaires c'est sur deux jours
premier jour il y aura des échanges
comme on vous l'a dit des rencontres
entre investisseurs grand groupe start
up y aura des pitchs qui sont organisé
un concours entre 25 start up et puis il
ya le 13 mai c'est le circuit de
l'innovation 14 sites de recherche à
découvrir alors quels sont ceux qui vont
être ceux découverts par les visiteurs
sur saint quentin en yvelines
le premier jour c'est vraiment le moment
où
nos entreprises vont pitcher vont
présenter leurs solutions et le
lendemain c'est le moment où on ouvre
nos centres de r&d nos centres nos
laboratoires aux visiteurs et nous avons
la chance d'avoir des lieux extrêmement
emblématique sur sur saint quentin en
yvelines c'est ainsi que safran airbus
le latmos mais aussi l'école de 1600
vont ouvrir leurs portes pour permettre
aux visiteurs de découvrir les
innovations qui le développent et puis
pour certains les formations qui sont
lancés alors à découvrir maintenant une
autre start-up qui va participer à paris
saclay spring il s'agit de appelé iaea
fleyhane elle construit en fait elle
conçoit une application pour essayer de
répertorier les matériaux qui peuvent
être récupérées lorsqu'un bâtiment est
détruit et pour cela elle collabore avec
sita et je vous propose de le découvrir
dans cette séquence business kayes
[Musique]
je m'appelle marie pierre ciminelli je
suis responsable d'agencé bâtiment
durable jessica et sita et c'est un peu
moins de soixante personnes qui tous les
jours cherchent à réduire l'empreinte
environnementale du bâtiment
[Musique]
je suis dominique renard brasil j'ai
fondé à plier en 2019 à fria c'est une
une entreprise hébergés à skis cuba
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines et la mission daf les ja c'est
de simplifier le passage à l'économie
circulaire dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
sa rencontre avec à fleyriat c'est c'est
un réseau commun entre notre direction
et dominique blazy le partenariat s'est
fait assez simplement par par la
proximité puisque btp consultant sita et
btp diagnostics sont situés à saint
quentin comme comme à fria on a eu un
besoin qui est de développer un outil
pour nous faciliter
pour nous faciliter la vie dans le
travail du quotidien dans la réalisation
de diagnostics et eux mêmes des produits
et équipements matériaux déchets
sita et et l'utilisateur de da kibo
l'assistant digitale du diagnostic le
diagnostiqueur va sur un sur un chantier
qui qui a pour but d'être construit en
partie ou en totalité
et va pouvoir quantifier
la matière sortante a qui bossent c'est
un outil digital qui permet de
construire facilement les scénarios de
valorisation des déchets sur des
chantiers de démolition et de
déconstruction une fois les données
collectées il ya un travail de
compilation de données et d'analysé de
retranscription de cette donnée-là et de
définition d et des potentiels de
valorisation pour chaque matière
[Musique]
l'intérêt pour nous une plusieurs ordres
techniquement un apport de compétences
sur l'outil est le concept de mise en
place d'un logiciel on est vraiment dans
l'innovation pour l'outil digital à kibo
on est dans l'innovation dans la
vitalisation du futur diagnostic est là
il est absolument nécessaire d'avoir la
proximité avec l'utilisateur final
puisque il faut que les fonctionnalités
répondent aux besoins donc là on est
vraiment dans le développement agile le
fait de passer par une structure
déportés qui est focalisée sur sur le
développement de son outil
ça nous permet de
d'avancer plus rapidement l'utilisateur
réagi
à ce qu'on va lui proposer on a juste
c'est donnant-donnant dans le sens où
nous on va apporter de la ressource
humaine on va apporter de la data on va
apporter de 2 du principe utilisateurs
et le besoin en fait pour cet outil-là
ce contact vraiment très proches avec
l'utilisateur final permet d'être
certain que les fonctionnalités que l'on
va proposer son sont les bonnes donc ça
ça permet d'accélérer en fait les
développements il a justement du produit
bon je suppose que h quand vous voyez ce
type de partenariat entre un grand
groupe est une start up ça participe à
la dynamique du territoire
nous sommes ravis quand nous voyons en
fait l'ensemble des ingrédients de notre
stratégie de développement économique et
d'innovation se traduire par des
partenariats concrets on a là un secteur
dans lequel 50 ans ni bean est en pointe
le secteur de la construction une start
up qui est accompagné dans notre
incubateur un partenariat avec un acteur
de référence du territoire tous les
ingrédients sont là réunis pour pouvoir
accélérer le développement de nos
startups et leur offrir cet écosystème
qui est dense et qui est un élément
moteur de leur croissance et justement à
ce propos sur les cas de collaboration 1
c'est pas nouveau il y avait déjà des
collaborations entre start up et grands
groupes pme et grands groupes avant la
crise mais on va écouter jérémy hervé
qui est directeur du développement
économique à l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay qui nous
parle justement de l'accélération de ses
collaborations avec la crise sanitaire
de plus en plus on se rend compte à quel
point la r&d est une fonction qui n'est
pas télétravail abl en tout cas pas
totalement que la proximité des
partenaires on recherche est essentielle
il faut avoir accès aux plates formes
techniques il faut avoir accès aux
machines il faut avoir accès
une salle blanche il faut avoir accès à
ses partenaires et est donc et donc la
proximité on s'est rendu compte à quel
point il est essentiel en recherche en
innovation alors l'innovation ça sera au
coeur de paris saclay spring le 12 et 13
mai 2022 donc la semaine prochaine et on
parle déjà de parisse avec les spring
2023 oui parce que évidemment c'est
aussi l'occasion de valoriser
l'écosystème de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et nous aurons
la chance en 2023 d'accueillir l'édition
spring à saint quentin en yvelines et de
mettre en valeur aussi donc ces
développements l'ensemble de ces
collaborations grands groupes qui sont
pour l'essentiel implanté sur saint
quentin en yvelines et start up sachant
que nous avons aussi créé des outils qui
viennent accélérer ses collaborations
notamment au travers d'un fonds
recherche innovation collaborative
enseignement supérieur que nous avons
lancé l'année dernière et qui d'ores et
déjà accompagne des projets
opérationnels donc quatrième édition et
parce qu'il faut le dire paris saclay
springs à se tenait uniquement dans le
département de l'essonne pour le moment
la cinquième édition donc celle de 2023
aura lieu dans les yvelines pour la
première fois et donc à saint quentin en
yvelines merci à une faillite est revenu
sur notre plateau directrice
développement économique à saint quentin
en yvelines et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
c